what has been your most unbelievable
moment today ah my most unbelievable
moments today you know what sharing the
day with my husband honestly he always
makes sure that I have champagne that
I'm well taken care of you know in the
right way you know we're not giving you
a little champagne oh oh in that way and
okay alright yes it's a good time so
that was an unbelievable moment of the
day yes but also to not to tell you I
chipped a chicken scratch the picture of
a dress on my kids notebook paper many
years ago before I was ever a working
actor and I said I'm gonna win an award
in this dress and this joyner wearing
this year Christian Siriano brought my
chicken scratch to life so I need to win
something cuz you predicted that you had
a premonition right yeah I willed it to
be so
hey wait Nazy is this husband wait you
were her most um you remember her most
unbelievable moment today unbelievable
moment yes she said you know a little
Erin baby you told them you care of me
if you know what I'm saying yes yes get
more prepared for the evening
absolutely yes yes yeah that's all right
you know we won't only tell a few
million people that's all wow I didn't
know she was gonna divulge that but yes
we're wishing her good luck tonight no I
think she already had good luck